[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
amanda knox was exonerated of murder in
italy now
she's sounding off about brendan dassey
from the netflix film making a murderer
most of us don't understand how someone
could falsely confess to a crime they
didn't commit
also attorneys for doomsday cult mom
lori balo
asked to move her trial plus it's back
to prison for the tv soap star
behind a deadly car crash and combined
total of 19 rounds who were fired
updates on the deadly shooting of a los
angeles man on a bicycle
and two ambush deputies lawn crime daily
covers court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to long crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmayer
and terry austin as always a suspended
illinois attorney pleading guilty to
murdering his five-year-old son
the mother of the slain boy pleaded
guilty to beating her son to death back
on april 14
last year prosecutors claim andrew
friend senior moved the boy's body and
buried him in a shallow grave
fathers agreed to serve a total of 30
years on three separate charges
those sentences will be served
consecutively or back to back
here's the reading of each charge and
the defendant admitting to each one
how do you plead to the offense of
aggravated battery to a child
honor about march 4th 2019 in mchenry
county illinois
guilty how do you plead
to the offense of involuntary
manslaughter
to a child on or about april 14th to
april 15
2019 in mchenry county illinois guilty
or not guilty
guilty how do you plead to the offense
of concealment of a homicidal death
honor about april 15th between april
15th and april 24
2019 in mchenry county illinois guilty
or not guilty
guilty prosecutors revealing some of the
gruesome details of that murder
in court defendant cunningham described
that night of aj's death to the
evaluator dr robert meyer saying that
she just felt a lot of rage that she
lost control and was
in an extreme rage when asked where
defendant fred was that night defendant
cunningham advised i don't know where
drew was that night
defender friend indicated that he was
woken up by defending cunningham at 3
a.m on april 15 2019 and was told by
defending cunningham that aj was not
breathing
after realizing that aj was dead defend
a friend indicated that he told
defending cunningham he would handle it
and place
aj's remains in a large plastic tote in
the basement
defend a friend so um i attempted to
resuscitate him monday night
and i know we dressed him and you know
tried to get him warm
but i don't obviously think but i don't
obviously that didn't work
defending friends so anyway i carry him
downstairs and we left him downstairs
until wednesday night april 17
2019. so um i put in a couple of plastic
bags and i
put him in the trunk of my car and drove
him out
obviously i will show you where that is
terry in illinois if there's a plea deal
a defendant must serve 80 percent of his
sentence 80
of 30 years is still 24 years so this
guy is not going to see the light of day
anytime soon
well that's right i mean the type of
crime we see here it would be great if
it were life but 24 years is going to be
good he's 61
now he'll be 85 before he can leave
prison and if you count time
serve maybe 84. so i think that's
significant enough and he won't be a
threat to society
when he gets out brian the boy's mother
is said to be the primary attacker in
some accounts she's
starting off with a 35-year sentence do
you think that the sentencing range
for the father here 30 years is fair in
alignment with the 35 years for the
mother
i think it is especially if you're
considering the mother to be the primary
aggressor but
what i really like about this plea deal
is that he has to cooperate with dcfs
to participate in the investigation of
his own son's case
hopefully that can prevent this
happening in other dcfs cases
explain that a little bit brian because
oftentimes when we watch cases like this
there's not a plea we watch a trial
would it cause constitutional problems
if a defendant was forced to
go along with an investigation if he
pleaded not guilty
not at all for most parts when you plead
guilty to a crime the the jail sentence
is really what the statute controls
but for these other aspects of probation
or being involved in some sort of
program
we actually see that a lot in
courthouses for low-level crime so
adding them to high-level crimes
is not really that peculiar and i think
for here it's greatly warranted and
greatly needed
terry are you in agreement here i am in
i thought it was a very very you know
creative way to deal with this issue
and hopefully save some other children
in the process
i think we're all in agreement that in
other words okay let's move on now to
developments in the trial of lori vallo
the idaho mother charged after the
bodies of her children
were found buried in her husband's yard
terry you have that report
yes just uh last week lori valo pled not
guilty to two felonies related to the
destruction
alteration or concealment of evidence in
the disappearance of seven-year-old j.j
valo
and 16 year old tyler ryan her attorney
wants her trial moved
out of fremont county idaho valo's
husband
and co-defendant chad day bell is also
scheduled to be tried in the same
county and prosecutors actually have
asked to combine
the cases among the evidence is the
secret recording of lori valo
purcell if you really loved me you
wouldn't have
told the police that i had jj with me
that's not that's not what a friend does
i do and i did exactly what i felt the
lord was instructed me to do anything to
harm you
i believe that you have been very
deceived by satan i believe that he has
tricked you
i don't believe that what you're doing
is correct i just don't i mean
tammy dies and then your husband died
and then this and then he's missing it
just doesn't sound like god's plan to me
valo's attorneys say they have no
problem with holding one trial against
both defendants
but they also say it should be held
elsewhere due to the volume of news
coverage
the case has generated so terry the
local newspaper has received reports of
residents being asked their opinions
about
this case that gets tricky the defense
needs to know the extent
of the pre-trial publicity but i've seen
prosecutors shoot back at some defense
attorneys by arguing that the surveys
themselves are poisonous so
if we assume that these are defense
surveys
are they the correct thing to do or are
they going to cause a problem
i actually agree with the prosecution
here the defense is canvassing
the local community to see if they know
about the case just by asking
questions it is going to make them know
about the case
plus you know when you think about it
there's no need to do a survey here we
know for a fact that every individual in
the state of idaho
knows about this case all they need to
do is make sure
that they can listen to the evidence and
apply the law and be
fair and usually you can ferret that out
during war deer when you sit a jury
right brian
exactly that's the point of juan dia
jury's selection
to go through those issues both as
defense attorneys prosecutors and even
the judge themselves would ask these
types of questions
so brian when it comes to publicity
causing an issue for a defendant the
rules tend to examine whether the police
or the prosecutors are speaking about
the case outside of
court here it seems to me at least from
where i sit that the officials are
handling the case
from a rather tight-lipped fashion the
evidence is being presented in court
so is there a problem here really
maybe unfortunately is the answer
because it really depends on what's in
these surveys
they're not coming out and saying hey
this is exhibit a and this is exhibit b
and this is what we're going to show
they're merely just asking the question
and depending on how those questions are
posed or asked
not giving too much information or
evidence about the trial they might not
be doing anything wrong
at least from a legal standpoint yes
that's the defense though that's
supposed to be doing the surveys at
least presumably the prosecution
though when the prosecution terry is
potentially
poisoning a jury pool through comments
outside of court that's what the rules
prohibit and they're really not doing
that
the publicity is being caused by what
we're hearing in court
well that's right you know my rule of
law here is just don't say anything at
all at least outside of court and inside
follow what the judge is telling you to
do
all right terry with the ethical way to
handle a case here on law and crime
daily and still ahead
more troubles for harvey weinstein and
for an actress from the hit series
melrose place
but first some leaders are demanding the
resignation of the los angeles county
sheriff
after a police shooting and protests
that's when law on crime daily returns
[Music]
the los angeles rather county sheriff's
department is releasing new information
in the fatal shooting
of a man on a bicycle deputies say they
attempted to stop
dijon kizzy on august 31st for riding in
the wrong direction
kizzy reportedly fled on his bike fell
down and then ran on foot deputies say a
struggle ensued and kissy dropped a gun
deputies shot 19 rounds killing kizzy
new video from the authority shows
different angles of the shooting here's
their explanation of how it all went
down
the first video shows dijon kizzy riding
his bicycle on the wrong side of the
street and the involved deputies
attempting to stop him
he then makes a u-turn in front of the
deputies drops his bike to the sidewalk
abandons it and flees on foot notice
that he has clothing in his hands as he
flees
the second video shows kissy running
north on budlong avenue from the
deputies
still holding the clothing the deputies
do not chase him but return to their
patrol car
the next video shows the shooting itself
it is graphic in nature and may be
difficult to watch
although it happens quickly you will see
one deputy approach kizzy on the
sidewalk as he attempts to distance
himself
kissy's arms are in the air briefly
still holding clothing in each of his
hands he struggles and ultimately hits
the deputy in the face
at one point kissy's pistol drops to the
ground
he bends over reaches picks up the gun
and is shot as he stands with the gun in
hand
the second deputy joins the first and
the deputy involved shooting occurs
authorities say there's no indication
the deputies knew who kizzy was but they
did learn more about him
after the shooting the ruger nine
millimeter semiautomatic pistol
recovered at the scene was loaded with
15 live rounds and is at the los angeles
county sheriff's department crime lab
for forensic testing these tests will
include
visual inspection functionality serology
and fingerprints we know that the pistol
is a stolen gun from las vegas nevada it
was reported stolen during a residential
burglary
in february of 2017. as part of the
investigation
the cellular telephone of dijon kizzy
was forensically reviewed
videos were discovered with show kissy
in possession of that same pistol
days before this shooting the shooting
sparked protests in los angeles
including the shooting of
two deputies just days later a manhunt
is underway for a suspect believed to
have
ambushed the deputies seen here sitting
in a patrol vehicle
there's a 600 thousand dollar reward for
information leading to the arrest of the
shooter
the sheriff says the deputies are
recovering one is at home
and the other is still in the hospital
and now to brian buckmeyer with the
arrest of a reporter covering some of
the protests that resulted brian
yes aaron josie hwang was using her
phone to record the arrest
when sheriff's deputies say she was in
the way she was close to the action but
other video of the incident suggests she
was not interfering
she says she was told to back up had
nowhere to move
and then seconds later was shoved to the
ground by officers who stomped her phone
some oversight commissioner have called
for the sheriff to resign
he responded by saying this the fact
that this motion is even being
considered particularly
when two members of our department are
recovering from a life-threatening
ambush
is morally repugnant and emblematic of a
political animosity
and the political appointment
commission so brian a lot happening here
we've got the sheriff being asked to
resign
we've got a shooting under investigation
involving an individual we've got a
shooting
involving deputies let's talk about the
the initial report here that was the
shooting justified
it's a tough question but it's a fair
question when somebody's going for a gun
after struggling with officers were they
justified in that moment
and pulling the trigger that's the big
question i i think it's going to be hard
either way however i would say it would
lean 51-49
towards being justified because the
officers are going to have a strong
argument to say
we did see a weapon he did reach for it
he did
have it in his hand and at that point in
time they're going to say that deadly
force was required
and the fact that they did not venture
to use deadly force
up until that point and they're going to
have a strong legal argument as to why
their actions were justified
brian breaking down the law for us here
on law and crime daily now terry
you've got some pretty harsh opinions
though about the way the sheriff is
handling a lot of things there in los
angeles itself
well yes i think that he can't really
talk about
the fact that his deputies were shot and
this case here and whether he should be
removed because of the way his officers
handled the shooting here so they're two
separate issues and one has nothing to
do with the other
the other thing i'll say is each case is
different and yes as a matter of fact
since you know this individual had a gun
the police officers
did probably think their life was in
danger but what i will say is
the reason that the stop was made
because the bicycle is going down the
street
i'm not so sure that should have
occurred in the way that it did occur it
wasn't as though
a felony was being committed in other
words there are many more serious
offenses that the police could target
than someone riding a bicycle
exactly and 19 rounds is certainly not
justified
good opinions here on lawn crime daily
still ahead find out why a judge has
ordered an actress best known for her
role in the tv series melrose place to
serve even more time behind bars for a
deadly drunk driving crash plus
former murder defendant amanda knox says
she was pressured
into confessing to a crime she did not
commit in italy
coming up next knox discusses another
case involving an alleged false
confession
made famous and a hit netflix stocky
series
[Music]
i recently spoke with international
murder exoneree amanda knox about her
new podcast and facebook series called
the truth about true crime among our
subjects was brendan dassey the
wisconsin man who as a teenager
was convicted of helping his uncle
steven avery kill freelance photographer
theresa halbach
the cases were made famous in the
netflix film making a murderer
i have looked into his case personally
because
of the false confessions aspect the
coercive
interrogations aspect especially towards
someone who is vulnerable
because he is young he is immature and
he
is trying to basically appease
these police officers by following their
line of questioning
and telling them what they want to hear
that is something that has deeply
concerned me because
i also fell victim to coercive
interrogations
i think the fact that there is zero
evidence linking brendan dassey to
um this murder is that the only thing
that was used
to uh convict him was his confession
is gross like it is a gross injustice
and he definitely deserves a new trial
and to be found
not guilty because the evidence just
simply isn't there
you coupled a couple different ideas
there so you're saying not only new
trial but you're saying flat out not
guilty
he reached the end of the line from an
appeals standpoint
so the u.s supreme court basically
didn't want to look further into the
circuit court's ruling
that basically affirmed the conviction
so where does he have left to go
it's basically a pardon from the
governor absolutely
and that's unfortunate because in this
country we have a principle of finality
once you've been convicted in this
country it is extremely hard to
re-examine
the evidence that was used to convict
you and unfortunately brendan dassey's
conviction
was compelling in the sense
that most of us don't understand
how someone could falsely confess to a
crime they didn't commit
but there was no evidence other than
that to support it
so what's really at stake here is we
cannot
legally go back to the the
trial level and say really what was the
evidence that we're looking at we're
stuck in a legal system that doesn't
allow us to
revisit that due to finality and so now
we have to
basically rely on the humanity
of our governors and our politicians
and us publicly to acknowledge that
we've made a mistake here
and that this person doesn't deserve to
spend the rest of their life in prison
is it a mistake to say that brendan
dassey is definitely
innocent or is it more accurate in your
opinion to say
the state couldn't prove brendan
dassey's guilt because i look at things
through the prism of burden of proof in
every case i look at
absolutely i would say that the state
does not have the evidence to prove
brendan dassey's guilt
and if anything there is evidence of
police coercion to bring to make brendan
dassey
make those false confessions that were
used to convict him in the first place
and when we come back celebrities making
legal headlines and an
update on the case of a man who
testified for the state in the
methamphetamine-fueled killing of a
young tennessee woman
the sheriff called the matter a
so-called deal with the devil
[Music]
the man who admitted he was present when
a young tennessee woman was murdered is
out of jail
jason autry testified that two other men
killed holly vobo
in the spring of 2011 and that he was
present for his testimony autry received
an eight-year sentence
with credit for time served he is now a
free man
queen elizabeth second stripping
convicted sex offender harvey weinstein
of his title as a commander in the order
of the british empire
weinstein received the award in 2004 but
earlier this year he was of course
convicted at a jury trial in new york
those who hold the royal title are
expected to remain good role models
a criminal conviction is one of several
general reasons why a person may be
stripped
of such a title actress amy lokane from
the tv series melrose place will serve
more time behind
behind bars rather after a deadly drunk
driving crash 10 years ago
a new jersey state court judge said
locaine's original sentence was too
lenient
and that she refuses to fully
acknowledge her guilt over the course of
the case various judges and appeals
courts have sentenced her to three years
then to five years and now to eight
years behind bars
witnesses testified her blood alcohol
level was probably around three times
the legal limit
and that she was driving about 53 miles
an hour in a 35 zone when the crash
happened
terry this sentencing range is all over
the place the case has been up the
courts down the courts
back down the courts everywhere is this
fair constitutionally speaking
i think that she has a really excellent
argument for
double jeopardy as you know the fifth
amendment protects
defendants from being prosecuted twice
for the same crime
and here she was prosecuted she was
convicted she was sentenced
and the sentence was within the range of
reality and within the range of the loss
so i think coming back at her again
is really unfair and she has a good
argument i think to beat that
brian buckmeyer do you agree or disagree
it's interesting i got to see what the
arguments are because from my
understanding the reason why they went
back and forth between
the the state supreme court and back
down to the trial court
is because it was an improper plea while
jeopardy does attach when the jury in
panels
for a jury trial or upon sentencing if
the sentencing is incorrect that might
be something that prosecutors are
hanging their hat on but
otherwise i agree with terry it seems to
be something that's pretty open and shut
when it comes from a double jeopardy
standard so this in other words might
bounce back around in the courts a
little bit longer it sounds
exactly this might be an issue that the
original judges might
have created an error outside of the
statutory framework for sentencing
and that could be the reason why
jeopardy did not attach but again
they were offered the the defendant was
offered something and took it so that
should kind of hold true back and forth
here we've got a little bit of
disagreement on law and crime daily but
hey look we're all friends it's the
end of the broadcast thank you for
joining us we appreciate it very much
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
right here on lawn crime daily
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
today
[Music]
you